the debates on Sky News I'm Neil
Patterson here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world does
anyone know what's happening the u.s.
demands greater transparency in the
washington post trial in iran ethics
morals even values can we actually trust
our politicians well let's start with
iran and here's what little we do know
the trial is now underway of the
washington post bureau chief and tehran
jason rezaian has been imprisoned for
ten months and his Iranian wife has been
denied access to the courtroom the judge
dealing with the case has been described
as the judge of death but there has been
a distinct lack of clarity as to the
charges let alone the evidence being
brought to support them well as usual we
are joined by the Democrat commentator
Geoffrey Robinson live in New York and
the conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams joining us on for us from
Washington at Jeffrey to you first how
worried should we be about this very
very worried eyranne under the mullahs
has this this terrible terribly cruel
habit of doing things in secret of
executing people of treating people
unfairly of violating all sorts of civil
rights it is an extremely worrying
situation and and there is President
Ford worry I point to the fact that my
old pal my dear buddy Bobby Levinson the
former FBI agent who was gone missing in
quiche island in Iran has been missing
for over eight years and the Iranians
have never once said anything I mean the
the cruelty that they have inflicted on
Bobby's wife Christina and the seven
children and grandchildren is is
unbelievable and I can say this about
the Iranians cruelty in the name of
religion is the ultimate blasphemy
Armstrong it is a favorite tactic or all
particular regimes that when they have a
beef with a particular country one thing
they can always do is fling their
journalists in jail you know you think
um if Iran was sincere about really
negotiating
turn over a new leaf especially after
the change of power in that country this
would be a fine example it would it's
one thing that charge someone over
legitimate charges when there's real
espa notch which we've seen throughout
the world all others all Jason was doing
is communicating the fact that we can
help you build relationships with Iran
typically where anybody would do in
offering their services and they use
this tripped up communications to say
nothing and so they can just that will
put anyone with any Iranian lineage or
connection to that country in jail at
will and do it what they want I mean
just think about this this guy has had
no access to medical uh medical services
are to his lawyer he only met his lawyer
within the last couple of weeks well the
last day or so in preparation of this
kangaroo court trial that he's about to
go through so obviously there's nothing
there they don't need to tell anyone so
you the question is how do you even
begin to negotiate soon with that kind
of mentality who can just randomly takes
around like you neyo a jeffery off the
streets if they determine they want to
use you for some negotiation chip and
just throw you in jail and just keep you
there fertility 12 months and like
Jeffrey just said about his friend for
eight years without a word it says
everything we need to know about their
country their mentality and why they're
isolating themselves from the rest of
the world gentlemen back to you in just
a second but let's get a fresh
perspective on this dr. Mayer dhadkan
sorry is a former iranian diplomats know
at living in london dr. cansada thanks
very much for joining us what is you'd
assessment of exactly what is going on
here but I think you have to make a
distinction between your government and
a judiciary in Iran which is dealing
with Jason's case the judiciary run by
the Conservatives and the hardline
clerics is a state upon itself and it is
part of the domestic struggle that is
going on between reformers people who
have tried to champion a different way
forward by for example negotiating over
the nuclear deal and those people who
want to hold on to
relics of the last 36 years so this part
of Jason's unfortunate problem has to do
with a domestic struggle that's going on
within Iran and this trial addresses
some of those issues particularly since
those issued those elements the hardline
elements who have not been in favor of
reaching a nuclear agreement with the
United States and the 5+1 find
themselves in a bad situation and have
nurtured this in over the past 10 months
in order to try and flex their muscles
and to address their domestic audiences
and say that they have not lost all so
doctor consult just I want to make sure
that I understand you correctly despite
the fact that of course the Iranian
office of the prophecy of the Iranian
president does carry some sway within
the state there are these competing
elements within the Iranian government
that I've essentially conspired at a
bitter person in jail to try and take
the wheels off that oil deal sort ofnot
the oil to that the nuclear deal that
we've already got to preliminary
agreement on well I think you could you
you can't put it as clear cut you can't
put this proposition in the very
clear-cut manner that you did but
certainly it has something to do with
that the judiciary considers itself an
independent authority just like for
example the judiciary and you know the
separation of powers so it said it says
that I am I am entitled and I have my
own authority to do various things and
I'm prosecuting because of this reasons
now I don't think that at the end of the
day and and you know something terrible
is going to happen to Jason President
Obama up until this point has refused to
link the nuclear deal on the table to
the plight of this Washington Post
journalist I mean it was that mistake no
sir absolutely not we do not negotiate
with terrorists and who hold our people
hostages we saw we can see that formula
goes nowhere it brings about even more
problems that shows you that you're
willing the bin for price the
president's absolutely correct and
holding to that principle I would
challenge something that your guest has
said he may eat in the
cated and in what he was stating that no
harm has come to Jason yet i would i
would challenge you by saying anybody
locked up in an iranian jail for ten
months away from their family every hour
harm is done to them you take away their
freedom the thing that separates us from
the rest of the world Jeffrey we are in
a very difficult situation I mean when
you here at dr. Krantz re saying you
know it is very difficult to negotiate
with these individuals they are a
separate part of the government at the
appear unlikely to want to listen to
anything I mean what ultimately can be
done well when well I I take exception
as well with something doctor can sorry
said about the fact that the judiciary
is its own person its own entity it's
not it answers to the mullahs it answers
to the hard right wing of the movies and
nothing gets done in that country
without the move is saying yes it's okay
so that the whole idea that the
judiciary is acting on its own is not
true it's doing the the bidding of the
hardcore of right-wing mulas now and and
Armstrong is absolutely right you don't
negotiate with terrorists and every
minute that that poor young man is in
prison he is being tortured he's being
true treated very very cruelly and
denied his civil rights but i would say
one other thing some friends of mine
from hollywood win on a on a junket to
iran as part of a film cooperation thing
and and what they found in tehran
isfahan and other cities were a
population completely at odds with the
government a population that was
terribly literate that liked America
that was very open and very happy to say
what they could and they knew where
those lines were I mean for example the
mullahs have outlawed satellite
television throughout around and yet on
every building you see the satellite
television dishes so they know that some
laws just are not going to be enforced
but when you get the judiciary on its
high horse doing the bidding of the
right wing mullahs then you have a real
problem and until you sort that out this
country will never ever ever evolve out
of the 7th century mentality that the
mullahs have put it in dr. Khan Solomon
what actually can then be done to see
you secure the release of Jason when
it's Jeffrey points out there is this
schism between the majority and those
hardliners
first of all you know I don't think that
what I said differs from the
interpretation which one of your guests
just gave right now the judiciary is
independent it's an independent branch
of the government it answers to the
mullahs because the head of the
judiciary has been appointed by the
Supreme Leader and as I said it acts
against the government the government
that has been elected by the people and
people whom one of your guests described
as being essentially pro-western
western-friendly and and totally
different in mentality and in composure
to the kind of actions that we're seeing
but when you talk about you know what
you're putting emotions aside because
this is an emotional issue and I can
understand why your commentators you
know how feel emotionally for this but
putting emotions aside this is not a
case that you're dealing with terrorists
you are dealing with a situation that a
journalist who has sought to go to work
in Iran knowing in advance that Iran is
what it is all the things that your
commentators are saying well well known
to him and to everybody else for a long
period of time so he chose to go there
and now he's been sort of tried on
probably trumped-up charges to which he
has to answer now this there's a process
and a method that has to to be followed
through when I said no harm in my
opinion will come to him is not as
you're one of your guests said that of
course he has suffered I'm not saying
I'm saying that at the end of the day I
don't think he's going to be punished
for espionage and some sort of
arrangement will eventually come around
which will let him sort of leave Iran in
one piece in other words I don't think
that any physical harm will come to him
in the end and I hope that I am right
but the fact is that you do not
negotiate with terrorists but you do
exert pressure on on Iran on the
judiciary through public opinion by
saying that you know that this is you
know that you know
try to make this more expensive for the
Iranian authorities to go through with
this you have to bear in mind that for
example somebody like mr. Zarif the
Iranian Foreign Minister is not on the
side of the judiciary President rouhani
they say that we don't know we are very
sorry that this has happened but this is
out of our hands because they are an
independent body now Iran works in a
particular way and you know you have to
bear that in mind and otherwise you know
just you might say random slow
sloganeering is nothing to get anywhere
dr. Murdoch consani thank you very much
for your time thank you you can catch up
with the Sky News debate on Apple TV
Roku on ketchup and of course on Sky
News com / us but moving on fraud
corruption transparency terms you'd
usually associate with third world
politics but with just 18 months until
the US presidential elections how
stretched are the models and ethics in
Washington well let's speak to Dan
Schwager the former staff director and
chief counsel of the House and Senate
Select Committee's on ethics and abele
capable of dealing with this it's
difficult to imagine a time mr. Schwager
that politicians in the united kingdom
and to the united states have been held
in such low regard what's to be done
well I think they are trying to make
great efforts forward with transparency
and with holding themselves in each
other accountable in in their peer
reviews the Constitution says the
Congress has to police itself and they
try to do that and they try different
steps and they try to be transparent but
I think what the public wants and there
are lots of groups that feed on this and
and lots of industries that feed on this
the public wants the great scandal they
want to believe the worst of their
politicians they want to believe that
that everybody but the person they voted
for is a scoundrel quote unquote and the
facts don't really bear that out of the
problems just make it is not just the
fact that politicians are seen
ultimately to be policing them seen
to be policing themselves to an extent
but you know that there's politicians
simply don't help themselves I think of
the perhaps the most recent example
those at members of Congress that took a
trip to Baku in Azerbaijan for a for a
conference turns out they were there
thanks to the funding of the state oil
company of azerbaijan and at the same
time whilst they're receiving gifts of
rugs worth thousands of dollars i mean
do you have to be a politician you don't
have to be a politician to see that that
perhaps doesn't give exactly the best
impression well first of all putting
aside the rugs and and you know the kind
of situation that you're in when you're
a public official and you're in a
diplomatic situation and you're in a
diplomatic setting you know the very
point that you're using this trip as an
example of how politicians just can't
help themselves this was a fact-finding
mission to a foreign country with energy
issues with with important Foreign
Relations implications and a lot of
members and a bunch of staff from our
legislative body traveled over there
they did it not on the public dime but
they did it in a way that they
understood to be fully in compliance
with the rules that have been set up and
it it I think it's very important for
our members of Congress and for their
staff to be educated to be informed and
fact-finding missions such as this are
extremely legitimate now what it appears
from the press and from the leak of a
report is that it might be the case that
the sponsor gave misinformation to the
members the travelers and to the ethics
committee that approves this trip and if
that's the case that is not something
that should be touring the integrity and
reputation of these members and staff it
is something that should be addressed
and you know there is a lot of public
disclosure about these trips there is a
lot of review about all of these trips
there are a lot of rules about these
trips that are complicated and that
people work hard to get right but when
it turns out that somebody has been
given misinformation and it turns out
that the sponsors weren't may not have
been on the
up and up all of a sudden we tar all of
the members and staffers who went to try
and get some fact-finding done so that
they can make better policy and they can
review our our own foreign policy in a
more informed manner and that's that's
unfortunate that they get tarred with
that but it's a product of this you know
craving for scandal that we seem to have
Geoffrey Robinson it does speak volumes
though doesn't it that this source of
this leaked report is commonly held in
Washington at the moment to be the
Office of Congressional Ethics itself
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute I mean this is obviously an
intelligent young man but my goodness is
he confused and to be an apologist for
ethical violations is quite incredible
considering the the office he holds no
no first of all Robinson's rule the
minute a public official blames the
press you know the bastards guilty
unequivocal second of all what do you
mean forget the rugs you can't forget
through because they're taking gifts and
then they're being sponsored by people
who have a commercial interest in
bending their opinion wait a minute
people who are not registered by the way
as lobbyists no no no no no junkets the
political junkets when a kind of
politician the congressman or senator
goes on a junket a fact-finding mission
and takes his golf clubs his swimming
trunks and is the 22 year old secretary
what a bunch of crap that is no no this
has to be cleaned up and seriously
cleaned up not just painted over the
cracks I'm sorry but the public if they
have a jaundiced view of politicians
it's because politicians have earned
their jaundiced view Armstrong have you
been on any junkets recently you know
what I actually cringe listening to uh
Dan swag I really I cringe cuz you know
I don't know you know anything about my
history and no child left behind where i
took a current track from the department
of education to promote No Child Left
Behind it was disclosed but I almost
lost my career literally almost lost my
career so I can speak on this let me
just a why I cringe at dad is that he is
the problem
because they are so blind and so
isolated from the rest of America that
it is not his fault he's been so much of
this culture he doesn't see anything
wrong with it in fact when he said
forget about the rugs I almost had to
lie myself I could not believe it but he
doesn't get it the bottom line is what
do you expect they had lost where
insider trading was okay they're big
they're going to the Congress work for
one hundred two hundred thousand dollars
and in a few years time they'll become
millionaires they passed laws like civil
rights laws and other laws that
Americans have that here too but the
members of Congress don't have to air to
themselves it is so it is so maddening
listening to him to realize why the
American people find Congress that gives
it the Lord's approval rating on anybody
of any of these entities the three
branches of government is why because
they become so blinded for their Audrey
protecting their members they feel the
loss that applied to the John Q public
should not apply to them and it's just
sad listed in here because he's still
trying to defend it it shows you how out
of touch Curtis is with this country and
especially the staff members who are
there in a blurs mr. schwager I suppose
I suppose I suppose you could argue that
those who taught themselves aren't
exactly setting a fantastic example I
think of Hillary Clinton using a
personal email account to send work
emails let alone her husband's rather
flew a definition of what sexual
relations are look there's no question
and as I said image is a problem and the
public wants to see a very high standard
and very high level and the members need
to take that into account but you know
before I worked on the hill I was a
corruption prosecutor and i prosecuted a
lot of public officials and I don't
remember any crime having an element of
if you blame the press you're guilty
that's just not accurate and to say that
there were ethnic evaluations by these
members when the sponsor may have lie is
not accurate and when I said forget the
rugs I didn't mean you should paste over
them but we were talking about the issue
of what is the problem here look some of
the members did exactly the right thing
with the rugs I don't know if any of the
others didn't we don't know the facts
and so to say that there are ethical
violations here is wrong and when
Armstrong Williams for instance says
there were laws that approved of insider
trading are allowed insider trading that
is wrong your facts are just wrong and
so it's impossible not to point out for
Malaysian effect you got it will not do
inside it straight until you change your
rules it is true you had to change the
rules because of the public outcry ah
point to a single law that ever said
members of Congress are allowed to
engage in insider trading it doesn't
exist it's a myth it's in the middle
pech hated because people like scandal
listen there was a time when members of
congress could buy stocks and companies
before it was released to the public
until somebody got wind of it and said
listen this is not right there is
something wrong with this picture you
kidding me of course if that's why they
had the past in laws in the first place
our scientists have never been allowed
to engage in insider trading whether or
not they have done so as a matter for
investigation now you might want to talk
about the speech or debate clause I'm
not being an apologist for the for the
Constitution that has the speech or
debate clause if you want to amend the
Constitution that's fine so being able
to prosecute them is one thing but
members of Congress have never been
allowed to engage in insider trading and
suggest they have is wrong now what did
they do when that allegation was made on
60 minutes despite people like me trying
to say that it wasn't that that 60
minutes was wrong well Congress
responded to the will the people the
desire and the pressure that they get to
pass laws to look like they're
addressing things that were never
actually a problem and the reason they
need to do that is because of this
misinformation that's being put out
there and and then they do have to
address a reality jeffries absolutely
right they are hurting themselves they
are missing the perception and so they
address a perception that's not based on
fact but that's not blaming the media
and acknowledging guilt by pointing out
in this information Jeffrey Jeff I have
done Jeffrey Jeffrey Don swagger has a
point there does he know the politics
suffers from a bit of an image problem
at the moment when you think of quality
or not thinking of the west wing anymore
we're thinking of house of cards
absolutely wrong dan schwaiger has the
just won the award for being the only
guest on this program who has completely
totally 1,000% United Armstrong and me
we are in absolute lockstep on this one
and he's the only guest to have ever
done it because when Dan tracker says
image is the problem he doesn't get it
image is not the problem greed avarice
self-importance ego is the problem and
until his office starts cracking down on
that it will continue you cannot be an
apologist and hold that job sorry damn
down your response yeah well I would
suggest that you can't get facts wrong
and hold the job that you guys have and
for instance I've watched a bunch of
your programs and I really enjoy it when
you two are united and it happens quite
a bit that you to get united against
guess so even those little bit of facts
it makes for great television it makes
for great scandal but you got to get the
facts right if you're going to accuse
people of ethical violations you're
going to keep people of corruption of
ego of breed of avarice you have to get
your facts right okay then let's take
the facts how long have you been in this
job I was a former staff director and
chief counsel of the house ethics office
and a council in the set up kicks off a
director and a vector as former counsel
and staff director how many successful
prosecutions for ethics violations did
you orchestrate you can read the very
lengthy annual report end of Congress
romance you just give me a number no no
don't don't don't get pushed question we
just give me a number how many
successful prosecutions did you oversee
well first of all the committee's don't
actually prosecute if you're talking
about how many times did we cite
violations and debris did we report on
kind again to import and in successful
prosecutions well I'm not again you're
confusing terms and so I don't know
which other aunt and the answer press
the arrow at the end and really that's
game you think semantics answer is zero
you did nothing while you were there you
turned a blind eye because you don't
understand the problem image is not the
rituals it's a turtle Lou
effort was not how they were there mr.
Smith mr. swagger effect I just want to
try to make the bring this back to the
to do the general point about political
corruption I mean I was mentioned a
moment ago the shift in the public
psyche away from at the West Wing to
something like house of cards is there
something inherent in the system that if
that encourages if not outright fraud I
outright flood then certainly
Machiavellian behavior I don't know if
there's anything necessarily in the
system that encourages fraud I think the
system does encourage a lot of
appearances of conflict Armstrong
himself referred to you know his
allegations against him in the past
about appearances of conflict and
conflicts of interest there certainly is
something in the system where you have
to raise as much money as you as you do
where the lobbyists are allowed to be as
involved as they are in how you raise
money that absolutely creates a horrible
appearance and encourages what many many
people consider to be conflicts of
interest but there is great divide in
this country the Supreme Court doesn't
believe in corruption at least half the
Supreme Court doesn't believe the
corruption exists Justice Scalia and his
dissent in 1992 a case outlawing
patronage said patronage is a great part
of our American system so there is
certainly a lot within our system I
would agree that encourages appearances
of conflicts and perhaps actual
conflicts if I could see you if I can
say this lil we're not here to attack
dad you know I respect that he believes
what he's saying hello appearance and
allegations are not always reality I
will be the first admit that but I'll
tell you what I'm willing to do because
we're also here to learn and especially
as a broadcaster order of stations
across the country now I want to learn
and do better I'm gonna go back and
revisit this topic because I'll ever
this is the first time that I'm hearing
that what six of it is reported about
insiders trading was false so I will go
back and do my homework and hopefully we
can revisit this conversation again
hopefully hopefully we can I'm afraid
we're going to have to leave it there
thank you very much mr. strago first for
your time but second for getting these
two to finally agree on something it's
my pleasure AB you're hell which is
possibly an appropriate point
point out that you two will be back next
week for no thanks both Jeffrey and
Armstrong thank you and that's your lot
for this edition of the debate you can
continue watching sky news on Apple TV
Roku on catch up and of course on Sky
News com but until next time goodbye for
me